do you guys still read youtube comments
uh first day yeah yeah first day i kind
of i kind of want to get the consensus
of the feeling yeah uh from the viewers
yeah yeah um because i feel like the
people who watch on the first day of
your core audience yeah yeah and those
are the people i care about hearing
about the most you know i want to know
what my the people who watch my videos
day one think
um because you know when the video
starts doing really well and it goes
outside of your audience it's really
really weird comments yeah you know like
uh
turn into not english yeah so
like my rent-a-boyfriend video like blew
up i knew i knew it was going to do well
because
it's very good clickbait like you see
that yeah i saw that and i'm just like
this is this is going to be out back
even if the video was me
even if the video was me just going like
a denny's and just like
texting a guy and saying i rented it i'm
sure the video would have done a million
views anyways because the thumbnail and
the title is so good oh yeah um
and like i said i knew it would so some
of the comments i got on it were just
like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are
these and it's like
ew is he gay
is men gay is it like
it's like and just weird stuff like i
bet he smells nice and all that kind of
stuff and just you just start to get
like the really strange comments coming
out so i don't really give a [ __ ] about
them um yeah but yeah definitely day one
i i check sorry i don't know i want a
whole explanation no no no no yeah like
yeah for me as well as like day one is
kind of like the consensus of like again
it's like it's the ones who subscribe to
you is the one that's always waiting for
your videos so it's like you know
usually
i i also don't just look at the top
comments either i always look at it from
no yeah
yeah you can't you can't always look at
the top comments because those are the
ones like if there's anything with
constructive criticism it's going to be
buried down somewhere yeah and i want to
those are the ones i want to find yeah
the most liked ones usually some kind of
meme that came out of the video which is
cool or quote from the video from the
video yeah i get it we all watch the
video yeah yeah the problem is that i
actually don't want to check the
comments half the time because i don't
want to check my youtube analytics
yeah that's me too i don't i i i
literally click on the video i'm just
like don't don't show the views
the comments all right to check the
comments on the youtube app on the
studio youtube studio app uh the first
thing that pops up when you open this
app is your views how the video is doing
and the amount of money you're running
and all that stuff i don't want to see
that stuff daily and the elusive
something out of time we've talked about
i don't i don't want to know how my
video is doing every day
counterintuitively i probably should
care you know any expert in analytics
would tell you that you should be
checking it and studying it yeah i've
been doing youtube for like five years
off pure gut feeling and i think i'm
doing all right i think i think i
understand what's going on yeah yeah
so i i don't want to look at that um i
don't care how much it's making i don't
i don't care how many views it's getting
i just i just want to read the comments
i don't check it that often because i
have to see that [ __ ] yeah and so i
can't for me it's just like is it
monetized good i don't need to see
anything else i'm satisfied yeah i kind
of i'd say a check every
two to three days now really once yeah
yeah because like i i i think i check on
the first day and then that's just it
like i just check is this are people
enjoying this video that's that's all i
need to know yeah and then i just kind
of leave it at that but i remember
before when i first started you'd like
there was a full [ __ ] week right you
i call it the honeymoon period where you
just you were so proud of this video and
you just like kept refreshing the
comments like and you're just like come
on there must be a new comment there
must be new coming and i like that like
that that period was like a full-on week
for me before when i when i release the
video and then
the longer you do youtube the lower the
lower that honeymoon period is yeah
until like it's like it's different
because if you're really if i'm really
really proud of a video i'm still like
checking more comments than like some
other videos for example
and i was wondering like is it the same
for you guys or is it just like the same
for every video now
like how much how how much do you guys
see youtube as a job is it just like a
completely a job now
i mean i'd be lying if i said it it's
not it's no longer a hobby i mean oh no
it is no longer a whole yeah it's no
longer a hobby
if it wasn't for
uh i think the job is what makes me have
to upload weekly yeah i wouldn't upload
weekly if it was on my own yeah yeah i
think i would do once a month because i
love like some videos i i
absolutely adore making like there's
this one video that uh has been in the
world i can't talk about it yet but it's
been in the works a lot of approvals a
lot of a lot of uh things have had to
have been done to get this video done
yeah but i'm hoping that when it comes
out it's gonna be amazing and it's it's
been like a passion project for a while
and that that's just like saying that i
would have done yeah you know regardless
like if i didn't make any money even if
it wasn't my job like i would have made
that
like regardless yeah nothing and so
that's amazing when you get that but
that only comes around i feel like twice
a year at most yeah you get like a
chance
yeah truly passionate really amazing
idea and everything seems to be kind of
working yeah you know you get all the
approvals you want you get all the
go-aheads you get all the you know
because you know especially
now it's we we do a lot of filming
outside of our house
in japan you need a lot of approval
stuff it takes a long time
um before it was just kind of like how
many hours can i put in on this thing
yeah now it's become the case of can i
get the right approval because sometimes
you just have to have a passion project
that was like i think that was me and
like the fake timeline i did because
like how when when did i first mention
that yeah like over a year ago and it
just got released like a few weeks ago
yeah because i'm just like was that a
passion project or a job sorry oh that
was a passion pokemon cause i'm just
like
i do really people
do people really want to hear someone
explain fate in 30 minutes
like well like
but like i had so much fun filming that
and i'm just like this is just a fun
thing to work on yeah yeah i think i
think everyone enjoyed it except for the
fake community for some reason they saw
they got salty about it oh yeah i mean i
mean like you you gotta you gotta you
gotta take you gotta take with a grain
of salt sometimes uh being an anime
youtuber you can very much piss off a
lot of different anime fandoms
uh it's you know it's
it's to me it's part of the job right
because i i feel like you know i feel
like with you
you're more of like a personality with
like who sells himself on just you know
i'm a guy living in japan and i like
anime right whereas i think me and joey
have had our fair share of experiences
where because we maybe say our opinions
of an anime or maybe like we've gotten
to a point where we can have like an
effect on the community then sometimes
you know sometimes people can be unhappy
with what we say i don't know
unhappy is a it's a very loose i'm i'm
i'm being very civil with the words i
use right now i don't know i mean
i'm your guys's friend obviously so i
understand yeah you know where your you
guys are coming from and uh yeah
sometimes i feel like [ __ ] out man
this guy's being real harsh on you guys
i see some of these comments like jesus
christ he just made a video about fate
chill out bro yeah chill out why do you
have to be so messed up i mean that's
why that's like i'd be lying if i said
like that wasn't one of the big reasons
why i don't make videos on like popular
or big franchises anymore because it's
like it doesn't matter if i'm praising
the [ __ ] out of it it doesn't matter if
i'm saying an unpopular opinion or
whatever
the fanbase is gonna get pissed off
either way just purely because of the
fact that i made a video on it
yeah i think cuz i never really i don't
know whenever i made videos about stuff
it was always like the kind of uh bl
communities and they're always just
really grateful that anyone was making
videos about that at all yeah
yeah it's weird right because like
because i've also like slightly stepped
into that when i made a video on killing
stalking yeah and that was one of the
most like praised by the community
videos i was like i thought i was gonna
get shot hand to god bro bl fans are
like the best fans ever man they are so
supportive of anyone getting in the bl
in any capacity they don't really give a
[ __ ] if you get [ __ ] wrong they're just
like we're just glad that someone's
appreciating it yeah yeah because it's
so niche and some of it it's like
amazing work that just gets overlooked
because it's gay like yes i mean you
know so it's amazing